natürlich will er zunächst einfach
einmal beweisen und demonstrieren wie
gut er diese corona infektion übersteht
wie gut es ihnen geht das eben im stande
ist weiter durch die gegend zu fahren
und das ist natürlich ganz klar eine pr
aktion
und man darf auch nicht vergessen dass
trump einfach ein ausgewachsenes
übergewichtiges kind es also er liebt
diesen großen auftritt er liebt es wenn
seine fans ihm zujubeln und ihnen ihnen
ihnen ihn bewundern und er braucht auch
regelrecht diese bestätigung also er ist
süchtig danach erst auch durchaus etwas
narzisstisch veranlagt und ich glaube er
hat das jetzt einfach sehr vermisst auch
in diesen letzten drei tagen der fast
schon einsamkeit also für seine
verhältnisse nur ein zehnköpfiges ärzte
team um sich herum also und ich denke
mal es gab auch in den letzten tagen
schon diese tv bilder von trump
befürwortern die auf den straßen waren
die ihrem präsidenten nur das beste
gewünscht haben mit gesangs chören und
schildern und das hat ihn wahrscheinlich
so ein bisschen auf die straße getrieben
aber du sagst es ganz recht
es ist natürlich unglaublich
verantwortungslos und er steht deswegen
ja jetzt auch schon in der kritik es gab
viele ärzte wie gesagt haben dass das
gar nicht geht dass er als positiv
getesteter infizierter in dieser phase
auch gerade am anfang wo man so hoch
ansteckend ist die gesundheit seiner
mitarbeiter aufs spiel setzt für eine
pr-aktion also man dachte ja zuletzt er
hat sich so ein wenig geläutert gezeigt
er hat viel von dem man ja gesagt ja
viel gelernt jetzt in seiner
videobotschaft es sieht nicht danach aus
genau also erst später von liebe und
sagt er hätte viel gelernt aber
irgendwie hört dieser lernprozess dann
darauf oder stop dort wo es dann um die
eigene lieder geht ja und neue umfragen
mbc hat jetzt eine 39 prozent für trump
und 53 prozent für beiden das sind
ziemlich deutliche zahlen bis jetzt
lagen sehr knapp beieinander
bis jetzt war die ganze zeit die frage
diese corona erkrankung wird sie donald
trump schaden oder ihm vielleicht sogar
helfen im aktuell laufenden wahlkampf
die zahlen sähen jetzt ziemlich bitter
für ihn aus auf jeden fall also beiden
läuft den da geradezu nur davon kann man
sagen 14 prozentpunkte also das ist
weitaus mehr als hille
clinton zu diesem zeitpunkt führte man
muss zunächst sagen dass diese umfrage
eher ein referendum über seinen auftritt
bei der tv-debatte ist denn die wurde
geführt am mittwoch und am donnerstag
also zwei tage in die zwei tage nach der
tv debatte und noch bevor bekannt wurde
dass trump an corona infiziert ist oder
sich infiziert hat aber dennoch muss man
sagen einerseits gibt es diese hart
gesottene fanbase da kann trump im grund
genommen machen was er will die stehen
einfach felsenfest hinter ihnen das hat
er bewiesen im letzten wahlkampf aber
auch in den vergangenen vier jahren der
legislatur er kann damit angeben dass er
frauen in den schritt fassen kann
er kann damit angeben wie er den die
stadt um seine steuerzahlung bringt oder
auf der anderen seite kann enthüllt
werden dass er vielleicht doch nicht so
ein reicher tüchtiger geschäftsmann ist
das schadet ihm in seiner base gar nicht
aber die reichten nicht für die wahl er
muss natürlich auch moderate
republikaner für sich gewinnen und auch
wechselwähler und da schadet ihm
durchaus sein krisen-management wenn man
das überhaupt so nennen will also dieses
ignorieren von corona dieses kleinreden
bei die jetzt sehen er hat wirklich auch
in seinem engsten umfeld alle maßnahmen
ignoriert und montiert ist jetzt selbst
erkrankt setzt aber diesen kurs fort
verantwortungslose politik und die
werden sicherlich da er für joe biden
für einen verantwortungsvollen politiker
stimmen mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bet schau dich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren